[Music]
brian two teenagers in custody after
police say they were on the run after
killing a man on friday
and one of them is the victim's daughter
it's a story the i-team first broke
vanessa murphy live at metro police
headquarters with an exclusive interview
with the head of homicide vanessa
denise both teens are facing a murder
charge and are expected to be
charged as adults one of them is the
victim's daughter the other
is her boyfriend police say they tried
to
cover up the murder with equipment like
a chainsaw
and then they ran it's definitely
disturbing when you have such young
a young man and a young woman that are
being accused of such a horrific crime
metro police say they found the body of
45 year old daniel halseth in this west
valley home friday
his 16 year old daughter and her 18 year
old boyfriend aaron guerrero are accused
of killing him
and trying to cover up the crime
lieutenant ray spencer is releasing more
details for the first time
there had been items purchased such as
lighter fluid that was used to
light the fire there was also the
purchase of a chain saw
and a circular saw and hand saw where
attempts to dismember his body were made
prior to the
fire the teens were missing since friday
lieutenant spencer says the teen
daughter had stolen her father's car
and there was also money stolen from him
both teens were taken into custody in
salt lake city utah tuesday morning
now that hopefully
they are safe and sound and i mean
they're in
the hands of the authorities uh i at
this point but
but at least they're not you know
out there on their own and i mean
they're both pretty young people
gabriel grosso is guerrero's attorney
reality sets in and we have to see
what's up and what the evidence shows
the family of hellseth provided this
statement to the eye team quote
our family is heartbroken this has
happened to daniel
we love daniel beyond words he loved his
children and was an amazing father
we asked for privacy and respect for the
family at this time
end quote lieutenant spencer tells the
i-team detectives were interviewing his
daughter tuesday
we do know that the father had recently
made comments that he did not want his
daughter
dating aaron
now in nevada a teen 16 and older is
automatically charged as an adult for
the charge of murder
however at this time we are not
releasing the 16-year-old's name and
that's until she appears in court here
in nevada now
as we've reported this story also has a
connection to nevada politics
the alleged victim daniel halseth is the
ex-husband of elizabeth helseth
she's a former nevada state senator
according to court documents they have
three children together
including the teen suspect reporting
live vanessa murphy 8 news now